WELCOME TO THE JUNE TENTH
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE HEARING I WE HAVE ONE
BILL TO CONSIDER THIS MORNING
SB THREE FIFTY BY SENATOR HILL
I DON'T SEE ENOUGH MEMBERS TO
CREATE A QUORUM. BUT WE GO HEAD
AND BEGAN AS A- SUBCOMMITTEE
AND THEN AS WE GET A FORMAL. IN
CREATE THE CORN SO WE CAN ON
HELL. I DON'T THINK MISTER
MCCAW. AND MISTER FRESH THE SUB.
TODAY NOTICE TO THIRD HERE ON.
MR HELL SB THREE FIFTY WOULD
YOU LIKE TO BEGIN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR AND-
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT SB THREE FIFTY.
PENSION YESTERDAY AND ASSEMBLY
UTILITIES I ACCEPT ALL OF THE
AMENDMENT AS PROPOSED IN THE
ASSEMBLY UTILITIES ANALYSIS
STARTING ON PAGE SEVEN. LAST
YEAR IN AB FIFTY FOUR THE
LEGISLATURE IMPOSED STRICT
CONDITIONS ON P. JEANNIE TO
EXIT BANKRUPTCY AS A TRANSFORM
UTILITY. THIS BILL SB THREE
FIFTY HOLD P. JEANNIE
ACCOUNTABLE FOR MEETING THOSE
REQUIREMENTS AND PROVIDES OUR
STATE WITH A FAIL SAFE. IN CASE
THE NEW P. JEANNIE FALL SHORT
OF EXPECTATIONS. SB THREE FIFTY
AUTHORIZES THE CREATION OF A
NEW ENTITY GOLDEN'S ENERGY. IN
NONPROFIT PUBLIC BENEFIT
CORPORATION WHICH WOULD STEP IN
AND OVER. IT'S OKAY I'M JUST
HAPPY FIRST CHECK SO WE CAN
CALL ROLE IN THE STAFF MODERN
YOU KNOW HOW POINT NOT A-
COURSE. IT'S ALL PRESENT THE
FOR THE- YEAH. BLOOM. CALDERON.
JOB NOT YEP HERE. YEAH ALL HERE.
THAT MOTION A MOTION BY MISTAKE
MEN AS SECOND BY MISS BALCONY
HAN I KNOW WHAT WE HAVE A
COUPLE MEMBERS WITH QUESTIONS
BUT WE'LL GO AHEAD. AND PROCEED.
THEY KEEP AND CHAIR AND I KNOW
THE COMMITTEE HAS A GOOD BROAD
UNDERSTANDING OF THIS BILL SO I
DON'T NEED TO GO INTO TOO MUCH
DETAIL I DON'T BELIEVE BUT- IT
REALLY THE PURPOSE OF GOLDEN
STATE ENERGY THE NONPROFIT
PUBLIC BENEFIT CORPORATE CAN.
IT WOULD STEP IN AND TAKE OVER
OF P. JEANNIE FAILS TO EMERGE
FROM BANKRUPTCY OR A P. G.
FAILED TO TRANSFORM. AS WITH BY
AB BEFORE. IT'S A STATE RUN YOU
TO. FOR FUEL THE STATE LARGE.
IMPACTS WOULD THE- WE HAVE TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS MADAM CHAIR
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AND I
GO TO THE TOP. THANK YOU- I
ASSUME THERE'S AN OPERATOR ON
THE LINE. THANK YOU SUSAN.
THANK YOU CAN WE- OPEN THE
LINES FOR. COLORS IN SUPPORT OF
SB. THREE FIFTY. YEAH LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
FIFTY PRESS ONE AND THE
DIRECTOR. SORRY TO HAVE THIS
GOING FIFTY. I THINK WE HAVE TO
DO WE HAVE TO DO WE FIRST HAVE.
TESTIMONY NOW BY WITNESSES
THEY'RE JUST AVAILABLE OKAY SO
ANY SUPPORTERS ON THE LINE
PLEASE. WE DO HAVE THAT MERRY
ROSE TARA AND A LOT OF TROUBLES.
AND THEY'RE LIKE THEY'RE BOTH
OPEN. I DON'T THINK WE'RE GONNA-TAKE TESTIMONY UNLESS THERE'S
QUESTIONS IF ANY OF THE MEMBERS
HAVE QUESTIONS FOR- THOSE WHO
ARE AVAILABLE TO TESTIFY THAT'S
WHY WILL GO DIRECTLY TO THE
LINES FOR AS SPEAKERS AND
SUPPORT. AND WE DO HAVE. LINE
NUMBER TWENTY FOUR. YOUR MIND
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THANK YOU THAT THE SHIP WITHOUT
WITH THE CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL
DIVERSITY- AND THEN THE BOARD
OF THE BILL WOULD BE AMENDMENT
OUTLINED BY MARY ROSE OF THE
EVERY CLAIM ARE POWER NINETY
EIGHT THANK YOU. THANK YOU. SB
JUST A BRIEF MOMENT FOR THE
OTHERS.
NINE SIXTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THE PEOPLE I WORRY
ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA AND WHAT
DO WE CLAIM OUR POWER POLISH
THAT COURAGE TO BEAT THAT TO
HAVE MERIT TRUCK ONE OF THE
WITNESSES HEARD AT THAT WE ARE
IN SUPPORT WITH AMENDMENTS TO
THAT THE BILL- ARE AMENDMENTS
INCLUDE- FIRST OF ALL WE
SUPPORT THE CONCEPT OF MOVING.
THE A WALL STREET OWNED THAT-
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITY AND INTO
THE HAND OF CALIFORNIANS THAT
ARE GLAD THAT THIS EFFORT IS
MOVING FORWARD WE'D LIKE TO BE
IN THIS BILL SINCE TWO- IT
DIDN'T OF MOST IMPACTED
COMMUNITIES PEOPLE FROM
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITIES THAT THAT
DISABILITY TO COMMUNITIES.
SURVIVORS IN MEETING PEOPLE
AND- ALONG COMMANDING ROLLED
SAID THIS IS A MAKING OF GOLDEN
STATE ENERGY WITHOUT THE LIKE
THE SEA TO. NOT THROUGH THE UC
BUT SOME OTHER ENTITY THE
LATEST. AS WELL AS- INTERESTING
ON A ACCURATE APPEALS PROCESS
WITH THAT MAC NOT TAKING CAN.
AND STRONGER IN FOURTH MEANT.
NOT HAVING AT THE AMOUNT OF ALL
STREET AT THAT THAT THAT ARE A
KEY. TO KEEP NEEDING THOUGHT
BACK THE GREAT THEIR- SO WE'RE
SUPPORT OF THE CONCEPT OF THAT
THAT THAT IN THANKFUL FOR TEN
HEALTH IT FOR. IF YOU WANT TO
QUICKLY AT THE THEY SPENT THE
CONFUSION ABOUT WHAT THE GOT
STRUCTURE THAT THE CONTAINING
FROM HOMEHIGH HAVING A TIME
FOLLOWING THE- BREAKNECK FROM
THE AND SO. WE WOULD NOT STAND
FOR THE PERMANENT APPOINTMENT
BY. OKAY WITH THAT BEING THE
WAY TO. BUT WHY SOME MECHANISM
FOR ADAM. ENERGY WHETHER THAT'S
RIGHT HERE'S VOTE FOR MEMBER OR-
SOME OTHER MAKE. HOPE THAT IT
IS CAN BE GOOD CAN. BY OKAY IT
DEPENDS CAN. SIR THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME UP I WOULD BE FOR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE NOW AND I
HAVE BEEN TO START I'M SORRY. I
AT THIS POINT WHERE TAKE SO.
HOPE FOR NOW. SO YOU AIMED AT
YOUR ORGAN THEY- AND YOUR PAY.%
ALSO THIS IS A FACE COMMUTE THE
COMMITTEE SO ALL SOME MEMBERS
BRING UP IN ON FISCAL MATTER IT
IS- ALL TESTIMONY SHOULD REALLY
BE. A LIMITED TO THE COST OF
THE BILL WHICH- IS TO MINIMUS
SO- WITH THAT IS THERE ANY
OTHER CALLERS WHO JUST WANT TO
VOICE THEIR SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL. AND MINE THIRTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
LINCOLN ALL OVER O'NEILL I'M
CALLING FROM THE SUN RIGHTS
MOVEMENT AND I'D LIKE TO SAY-
A- THEM IN BETWEEN I SUPPORT-
WITH THE AMENDMENT- PUT FORTH
BY THE RECLAIM OUR POWER
COALITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
AT NINE SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING- MY NAME IS
PLAN WITH THE WEEKLY MY POWER
IN PAIN- I'M ALSO THREE HERE-
AND SUPPORT THE AMENDMENT THAT
FEATURES MENTIONED AGAIN BOB
WHAT. THE PLANNING AS WELL
THANK YOU. ONE TWENTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. I'M OUR ROAD
REPRESENTING THAT HE'S VERY
CLEAN POWER ALLIANCE. WE TAKE A
WE SUPPORT THE BILL AND
CONCEPT- BUT- FEEL IT'S
IMPORTANT TO MAKE THE- CHANGES
THAT WERE OUTLINED BY THE
RECLAIM OUR POWER CAMPAIGN WAS
PARTICULARLY CONCERNED THANK
YOU OFFER A PERMANENT
GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE THAT
DOESN'T- REPRESENT OUR
COMMUNITIES. THANK YOU WE ARE
TAKING ONLY YOUR NAME YOUR
POSITION IN THE ORGANIZATION
YOU'RE WITH AND IF IT'S SUPPORT
WITH AMENDMENTS YOU SIMPLY
STATE SUPPORT WITH CHANGES
SUPPORT IF AMENDED THANK YOU.
NINE TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MANAGER MEMBERS MIKE
MONICA AND ON BEHALF OF THE
COALITION OF CALIFORNIA UTILITY
EMPLOYEES. IN THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK. AT NINE TWENTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS BENJAMIN THANK WITH THE
STATE DEMOCRATIC SOCIALISTS OF
AMERICA I SUPPORT IT'S AMENDED
WITH RECLAIMED MY POWER
CAMPAIGN FIVE POINT THANK YOU.
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SUPPORT SB THREE FIFTY
PRESS ONE AND THIS AND- ZERO AT
THIS TIME IF YOU HAVEN'T. CUED
UP. AND ONE MOMENT PLEASE. WE
DO HAVE TO FURTHER COMMENTS
OKAY. IN MY TWENTY THREE YEAR
LINE IS OPEN TWENTY. HI MY NAME
IS THAT GENTRY HAGENS I'M WITH%
THE SUN RIGHT MOVEMENT AND I
WOULD LIKE TO VOICE SUPPORT
WITH IF THE NINE DAY THAT WITH
THE RECLAIM OUR POWER CAMPAIGN
FIVE POINT. THINKING IN MY
FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
GOOD MORNING THIS IS SHAUNA
LAZAR OUT COMMUNITIES FOR A
BETTER ENVIRONMENT WE SUPPORT
IF AMENDED THAT FOR THE RECLAIM-OUR POWER COALITION BLATTER
THANK YOU. THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS IN THE QUEUE. THANK
YOU ARE THERE ANY- SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF S. B. THREE
FIFTY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE NO ONE IN
THE QUEUE AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU IS THE- AID DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. REPRESENTATIVE. EIGHT
HEARING NONE- WILL GO HEAD TO.
COMMENTS FROM- MEMBERS ARE
THERE ANY COMMENTS. SEEN AND I
WILL ASK TWO QUESTIONS- THAT
HAVE COME UP AND I THINK ONE OF
THEM YOU HAVE ANSWERED
PREVIOUSLY BUT- THERE'S SOME
LANGUAGE REGARDING VICTIM
COMPENSATION IN THE INTENT
LANGUAGE THAT. I UNDERSTAND
YOU'RE WILLING TO CHANGE- VIA
AMENDMENTS ON THE FLOOR. OF WE
ARE THE MEMBERS THAT WERE TAKEN
YESTERDAY WILL BE TAKEN ON THE
FLOOR OKAY AND THROUGH THIS TOO
SO YES- WE- DO HAVE SOME
AMENDMENTS AND SOME CHANGES TO
THE IN TANK LANGUAGETHAT- WILL
BE PART OF THAT YEAH. THERE IS
ALSO QUESTIONS THAT I RECEIVED
THIS MORNING FROM A MEMBER WHO
IS SOMEHOW NOT HERE YET BUT I
KNOW HE WANTED TO VOICE HIS
SUPPORT AND I THINK IT WAS THE
SAME HERE IN. TOWN I. CAN
OVERSIGHT OR ADVISORY GROUP TO
BE CREATED SEPARATELY AND HAVE
AN ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
POSITION ON THAT IT'S BEEN
DESCRIBED ME AS SIMILAR TO. THE
LANDS SB THREE FIFTY TWO I'M AS
WELL SO I AM I HOPE YOU WILL
CONSIDER WORKING WITH THEM IN I
APPRECIATE HEARING THAT IN IN
THAT- AND I HEARD ON THE FOR
THE CALL AS WELL AND I THINK
THERE IS THE OPPORTUNITY. AS
FOR TWO NUMBER ONE IS YOU KNOW
IN THE NEW BOARD THAT WILL BE
CREATED IN THE LONG TERM THAT
WILL BE REPRESENTATIVE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT IS THE GOAL
WE'RE NOT GOING TO HAVE HEDGE
FUND BOARD MEMBERS WERE GOING
TO HAVE CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS
WITH THE SKILLS MATRIX AND I
THINK THAT THAT BOARD. WHEN
THAT SKILLS MATRIX IS
ESTABLISHED FOR THE OPERATIONAL
BOARD GOING FORWARD.
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE NEEDS TO
BE PART OF THAT AND WILL MAKE
SURE THAT THAT'S- WORK THROUGH
THAT IN IN THERE THANK YOU.
PERFECT THANK YOU FOR
ADDRESSING THAT WITH THAT IF
YOU'D LIKE TO RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE I THINK WE'RE
READY I DO. YES I WILL THAT
GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL WITH
MISTER DALI MISTER DEEP NOT
VOTING. AND THE ACTION WAS DUE
PASSED. TO INCORPORATE A MOMENT
SCRIBE ANALYSIS OF THE BILL BY
THE COMMITTEE ON UTILITIES AND
ENERGY AND AGREED TO BY THE
AUTHOR AND NOT COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU MISTER HILL THANK YOU I DID
I SEE MISTER DALI I'M SORRY MR
HOLLEY. FIRST AND LAST TIME I
MAKE THAT MISTAKE I PROMISE SO
THAT WAS A B. ROLL CALL WITH
MISTER ALI AND MISTER DEEP NOT
VOTING THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER HILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THAT CONCLUDES OUR PREPARATIONS
HEARING THANK YOU.